I was blessed to be able to work with
James on and off for about three three
and a half years doing the same project
fences we started in at Yale we went to
when I was a second year acting student
at the Yale Drama School we did it then
we went to Chicago then we went to San
Francisco and these were you know months
were in-between these were like seven
eight nine months in between these I
remember at Yale when fences was first
mounted during the rehearsals no one
spoke to me much I was the youngster and
so I was so green you know I just kept
quiet and I watched everything everyone
was so relaxed and free with each other
they were these there were these
anecdotes and stories just literally
flying around the room that first week
but I was struggling I was just trying
to find out what to call him I didn't
know mr. Jones
everybody was calling him Jimmy he's not
Jimmy but I couldn't figure out so I
just called him Sir which dovetailed
nicely with the play because that's
exactly what my character Cory called
him yes sir I remember at the Yale
rehearsal Lloyd Richards the legendary
director the first african-american to
be nominated for a Tony for death best
director and our Dean of the Drama
School pulling me aside and telling me
nothing Courtney if James were any other
star he'd tell you himself so I'm going
to tell you you are upstaging him when
you speak to him on stage stand
downstage of him so the audience can see
him I said oh that's what upstaging is I
didn't know I didn't know I can only
imagine how his eyes must have rolled up
into his head I remember it Yale at the
rehearsal that Lloyd Richards let James
and I giggle through the famous how come
you don't like me sing for the first two
weeks of rehearsal we just once we got
up to that scene
we just started I would look at him and
he would look at me and we would start
giggling and the director Lloyd just let
us giggle and then after about two weeks
he looked at us both and he said okay
let's go in now and the tears flowed for
the next three years
I remember Lloyd pulling me aside during
the pre Broadway run at the current
Theatre in San Francisco and telling me
now Courtney choose to physical gestures
of James rather than find two places to
place them in the play after doing the
play on and off for almost two years
under exactly which two gestures and
exactly where they went James always did
this gon cut them bows and the other
physical gesture of his was so I knew
that where this one went I would tell my
little sister at the end of the play
going back in the house and tell mama we
going to the funeral and the other one
was where I told my mother I don't want
to be like Troy max and I want to be me
and of course the audience just James
when you see this I want to personally
thank you for mr. Jones James Jimmy all
of those names sir for allowing me all
these many years to be part of your
family you you will never ever ever ever
ever know how deeply you are ingrained
inside of me I was blessed to be given
the acting challenge to grow into you
and I'm ever so grateful for the
opportunity it changed my life and and
now James if you don't mind I'm talking
to you like you're here James Jimmy if
you know if you don't mind I'd like to
sing you a little song that I think you
may have heard before for those of you
who don't know it's called old dog blue
it's a song from the play that James's
character Troy taught my character Cory
when I was
when he was aji I was a little boy it is
a song that helps Cory with that
difficult transition into manhood that
all young men must navigate old dog had
a dog name was blue
you know blue was mighty true you know
blues good old dog blue treat opossum in
the hollow log you know from that he's a
good old dog had ring had ring blue
treat opossum out on a limb drool looked
at blue looked at me and I looked at him
grabbed that possum and put him in a
sack blue stayed there till I came back
old blues feets was big and round
never loud a possum touch the ground but
old blue died and I dug his grave I dug
his grave with a silver spade let him
down the golden chain every night I
called his name gold blue you could all
you go blue you could all you blue lay
down die like a man
blue lay down and die like a man
now it's tree and possums in the
promised land I'm old tell you this to
let you know Oh
blues go home with a good hook school
when I shower blue bar when I have blue
bar blue treat a possum in those blue
treat a possum
that's the way that go
Thank You pop
you